um and what else did you want me to say
name and relationship status my
relationship status it depends on who's
asking okay I need to I need to break
that down why do we like that so are you
like are you okay so are you with
someone like someone you like
no it literally just depends on who's
asking speak to him well oh sorry well
I'm just wondering if you have a
boyfriend or not
it literally depends on who's asking
okay so if an ugly guy asks you have a
boyfriend if a handsome guy asks you
don't exactly and either one is kind of
just like whatever it is it is okay do
you you think that'd be a little
confusing for a guy yeah but that
doesn't matter that's up to me okay well
I know it's up to you but I'm just
wondering like yeah you know because if
a guy if a guy said if I said do you
have a girlfriend and he's like depends
who's asking I'm like do you have a
girlfriend
no of course you're gonna get like
irritated with it but at the same time
that's my business and if you're not
doing anything to court me to get in
that situation that I don't owe you
anything I just wonder why as women we
have these confusing answers instead of
just like answering questions directly
because guys do I don't I really don't
think that's true they do because I've
done I've done hundreds of these shows
and I've never had a guy give me an
answer like that it's either single
taken sometimes they might say I'm
seeing someone but like it's very a lot
more clear than the women in general I
haven't done hundreds of these shows but
I've done thousands of people
approaching me okay that's the thing and
the men so what are the answers the men
usually give like a man when they're
like like coming for me I'm just like do
you have anybody at home well baby we
ain't even talking about that right now
so so so so yes they do yeah but it's
like I can't do it too so like I'm one
of those people I could do it too well
yeah but then you're trying to be a guy
and no I'm not trying to be a guy I'm
just trying to have an even platform
that's the problem is a lot of people
try to think that like I'm trying to be
a guy I'm not it's just like if you
could do it why do the why do you think
that you can do it just because you're a
man and I can't do it because I'm a
female so my question is you said that
the men need to court you but they can't
Court you if you don't give them answer
if you're in a relationship or not most
of them don't even ask to be
honestly do you feel like you deal with
traditional men hell no well okay there
you go there you go yeah but I'm saying
like his traditional mental ass like men
that are trying to court you they'll ask
no and I agree with that but like there
you go traditional people are starting
oh sorry the traditional men are
starting to like extinct if like anybody
knows they literally they don't care
about nothing they're like okay you know
like I've been trying to date you do you
want to [__] and then the next one wants
that's not a traditional guy though no
no not traditional sorry I mean the
non-traditional guys that like approach
you are like uh like who are you would
you like to [__] and after that can you
take care of me why do all these guys
nowadays but it's like why do you deal
with the guys that want to be taken care
of I don't but then how would you know
this because you wouldn't know this
information because they approached me
well but then why are broke guys
approaching you you know what I'm saying
like it's like bro guys
but I'm saying like traditional guys are
going to be turned off by that answer
because like traditional guys don't want
to deal with the [__] so it's like
you're almost like adapting for the
non-traditional guys you know what I'm
saying like and it's going to turn off
someone that's traditional because
they're like are you taken are you not
this is too confusing on to the next I
100 agree with you but what I do is I
read the room just the same way as I'm a
VIP host out here I know the kind of
people that I can proposition of buying
bottle service at the club because they
can afford it I could tell by your shoes
by your watch by your shoes who I can
approach about buying bottle service at
a club the same way that I can like show
who I'm gonna do that answer to somebody
who is like not worth my time is what
who gets that answer but somebody who's
traditional probably worth my time but
will never get it but you know well but
you realize like traditional like I have
1.7 million subscribers and a lot of the
guys that watch are in a more
traditional mindset so it's like by
giving this and answer you're basically
telling them you're not a traditional
woman because traditional women don't
answer like that which is fine it
doesn't mean like bad person but I'm
saying like if you want to attract
traditional men the I just think they're
going to be confused that's also kind of
your opinion of the traditional guys
like the guys that like are like into
you you don't really know no actually
the objective truth is most of the guys
that are traditional and high value men
we look for a certain thing or a status
in a woman so if we're talking to a gal
and it's like they give us this vague
answer it's like okay she's seeing
somebody or not she won't give me an
answer and then it's like do I want to
deal with it right well yeah and then I
think they just think you're [__]
yeah I would I don't know
it's like wait it depends on who's
asking it's like okay are you are you a
man or a woman well it depends on who's
asking it's like okay I'm just trying to
talk to you it's difficult never mind
right but I hear what you're saying but
I think that when you have that many
subscribers you deal with guys like that
that deal with women
I mean we some guys don't have to deal
with it some don't you know and I know
your bottle service I I get that no no
but I'm VIP I loan juice bottle service
I'm not the girl
I was so independent host yeah I'm
independent but I used to be at one Oak
exclusively okay but then I decided that
it's like a lot easier to ask my clients
where would you like to go as opposed to
being like can you please come here I
know you really don't want to come here
but can you come here for just me no
that makes sense and like honestly if
you know anybody who's like a VIP host
we're trained to like really read people
sure and that's how I am so like when
I'm seeing those kind of responses I'm
saying that to the people I know are
jokes I don't say that to people of what
like oh yeah
you're a joke bro but I mean girl I'm
not I'm not gay I'm not gonna [__] you
no shade right but what I'm saying it's
just I think I think it's confusing to
guys it's my only Point all right what
about you um
I know it keeps coming down I don't know
what else I can do because I keep
adjusting it but there you go
well don't make it come down here
testing can you hear me yeah okay
um my name is Asia I am
25 years old and what was the other one
name age relationship status and what
you do for a living
name age
what I do for work right now I'm an
apprentice bartender for the MGM Grand
so that's really cool and
my relationship status is single
quick and simple black ice I host Black
Ice reality check and I run a tech
consulting company a supplement company
I am old
for you
ship uh with my girlfriend it's fine
yeah and you put this
right yeah well actually actually was
responsible for getting these ladies
here and we have the relationship we've
been on a couple shows so yeah
absolutely so it's got a nice little
podcast where he he interviews women and
like helps them out relationships
nice little podcast
[Laughter]
saw me I didn't like that I did it I
didn't mean it like that sorry I'll be
real masculine right now
[Laughter]
I just
I didn't I didn't mean it like that
you know what's funny he's such a good
interviewer that I literally I messaged
you I wanted to come on you did I was
like I thought it was a joke at first no
I was serious I thought you were I was
like I love the way he talks to the
women I was like he does such a good job
of like
um saying it in a way that's like
doesn't make us want to like punch you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sit over there I already saw it from the
beginning
I'm playing with you I'm playing
here we're just like so if you go I was
like is he gonna kick me out or not
because you're gonna be like Myron on
fresh and fit I'm like
Oh no just kidding no shade go ahead
go ahead I interviewed ladies on
relationship single women and why
they're single or not what they're
looking for in a relationship they want
to get married and so I do what kind of
Kevin did but I do it in person yeah in
a different level right yeah and I think
it's really gonna blow up I mean I I
literally I saw a clip yeah
I'm messing with you
that's what all the women say I didn't
mean it I didn't mean it and we don't
have to agree on like every single thing
but it's about him being like all right
get the [__] out [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] well and I'm just like well was
she being a [__] or not
I mean I like that she's being more of a
boss [__] and you like can't like
handle a [__] like that no I'm not even
no no no no but but I hear what you're
saying but there's a level of disrespect
when you're standing up yelling at
somebody it's like well she wasn't doing
anything I don't know who you're talking
about but I'm just saying usually okay I
used to actually think Myron was a dick
I really did and I I feel bad because
then I actually got into his shoes and I
interviewed women and I did all these
shows and it's so crazy because you
don't see usually the level of
disrespect they'll do first yeah and
over talking someone on their own show
and feeling like they own the room and
then it's like by the time you kick them
out it's like they've over talked you
ten times have you you've kicked women
off your show yeah not I'm not as um
quick as Myron no you're like yeah I've
seen it yeah but it's like usually like
a lot of times they'll play the victim
and be like oh I saw the one that you
did with Andrew Tate and auntie and um
yeah
oh my God yeah that was a hard one to
watch but then the African girl like the
younger one not Auntie yeah yeah yeah
yeah she was crazy yeah she was giving
it was crazy after that she was like
Pearl's so racist i'm like [__] you've
been on my show three times
of color I know but it was like but it's
like a lot of times when women get
kicked off they just like play the
victim when it's like they usually have
like 10 different warnings and then they
get it was really disrespectful I I
watched that thing I was actually
surprised to be fair with Myron [__] he
was talking over like the whole goddamn
time and then he just wanted like to be
able to pick on other people like that
[__] all right so like honestly like
with you guys y'all completely just
disagree with my opinion but I never
felt offended one bit I felt like you're
entitled to your opinions and I
respected the hell out of it but the way
that he comes at people well and I'll
tell you I'll tell you what's happened
though I think women we've never really
had people talk to us in a more
masculine way because women just
policemen's speech and like when we say
it's how you say it that's saying say it
in a more feminine way have you ever
been in a locker room with guys or like
in an all-male wait wait wait have you
ever been alive
[Laughter]
I mean there's a reason we have phrases
like locker room talk right right
because men roast the hell out of each
other like they are they are so rude if
you're black you understand that because
you know yeah because it's it's every
day
it's not what you say it's how you say
it people are always correcting my tone
right all the time right is that women
correcting your toner man both it's it's
much when a man does that how does that
make you feel it makes you feel like
he's a [__] yeah
right because
it's in way of talking right so I think
with Myron and I had this gut reaction
to him at first too but the thing is
with him it's like he's just speaking in
a very masculine direct way and most
women have never had guys talk to us I
don't think he's ever had the [__]
smacked out of him I don't think it's a
dirt by who he was a federal agent yeah
a federal agent do you think he's scared
of some [__] no no I'm saying like
you're like he never really got like
somebody who really [__] stood there
in that damn girl as a federal agent it
doesn't matter if you're you could be a
[__] president or you can be like a
government official and when you get
somebody that you really respect that
[__] tells you some [__] then it like
it I saw it I saw him have someone like
come to his door and like threaten oh
yeah yeah I saw that yeah I don't I
don't know he stood his ground he stood
his ground yeah
I don't think it's like the directness
of like how he is because I think being
direct is how he has to be because
unfortunately especially with the room
of women they start to over talk
everybody you have to command the room
and like calm it down I think sometimes
what it is is the the what words you
choose to use so like I've heard him
called girls [__] and it came out of
nowhere and it's like whoa like well
usually they're being a [__] so I think
that's I think that's what it is so it's
just like like let's say you're talking
to somebody because we're not used to
Turner Michael because we're not used to
like the like you said like people
telling us what to do and holding
ourselves accountable
we always want you to be like well what
you did wasn't okay
yeah usually what it is and so when we
hear somebody go say this they're like
what we want to man up like what the
[__] did you say to me yeah like you're
not gonna talk to me like that right so
yeah but and like that's kind of what
I've conditioned myself to like when I
hear guys speak in a very direct way I
have to ask myself first is it true yeah
so it's like was she being a [__]
probably like all the girls I've seen
him kick off over talk to him at least
like four or five times and there's an
element of alcohol involved there's a
lot of them were drinking before I'm
like this girl
yes as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible